always a lot of fun to watch lance lin
and he is on the hill as the sox make
their return to guaranteed raid field in
what we expect is going to be a huge
crowd tonight and over the weekend
for a massive series between the sox and
the cleveland indians
a little jam shot up the middle and it
gets in for a base hit and zimmer is
aboard to start the game for cleveland
and that'll bring up ahmed rosario
swings at the first pitch shoots it to
right field that is going to get down
and go to the wall
stumbling is garcia around second into
third easily is zimmer and ahmed rosario
with a double and the indians have
things set up nicely here to start the
ball game and here's jose ramirez inside
did it hit him on a check swing and it
hit him on the arm he did check his
swing he got hit on the arm and the
bases are full of indians for fran mill
reyes and he's got a chance to do some
early damage
swing to the first pitch knocks it right
back up the middle that'll get zimmer
home here comes ahmed rosario throw goes
to third ramirez is out at the bag
ramirez doesn't believe they got him but
regardless the indians have a
two-nothing lead his friend mil reyes
picks up rbi's number 48 and 49. another
cut fastball that's middle of the plate
now harold ramirez with friedman reyes
at first base and one out
3-2 struck him out lancelin's first
strikeout
the second out of the first inning
daniel johnson left-handed hitting right
fielder reyes goes on 3-2 swinging a
miss strike three
on a fastball
and lance lynn not too happy with the
way that inning went but he did limit
the damage somewhat
j.c mejia will be starting pitcher for
the tribe mejia 1-6 on the year with a
7-52
e-r-a the former cleveland indian and
now chicago white sox second baseman
cesar hernandez who gets a very warm
welcome from sox fans here for his very
first socks at bad that is a fair ball
and a tapper and perez does throw him
out for round number two in the first
inning here comes jose abreu the number
three hitter first pitch
slider
hits abreu
right in the back pocket this is a
slider that just gets away abreu will be
on and gavin sheets will be the tying
run of this first inning swung on skied
in the air
right field shallow foul ground now the
second baseman ernie clement over there
to grab it and jc mejia has a good solid
first inning now you chang playing first
base he plays all four infield spots
check swing i think he went around he
did
that's that selective swing that was uh
selective to not get hit
so the indians have their fourth hit
back to the top and zimmer there he goes
the pitch is swung on a miss strike
three two strikeouts in the first two
more in the second for lance lynn
leading off for chicago in the bottom of
the second inning johann moncada and he
swings and sends one high and deep to
right center field bradley is back at
the wall he jumps with johnson and
neither one caught it and this ball is
where it's a home run they ran into each
other and the ball cleared the fence
it's two to one
wow how about that you can watch
millions of baseball games and never see
that
in your life all-star teammates matching
up here lynn to jose ramirez
struck him out change-up dancing for
lance that was his best pitch of the
night because he took down a really good
hitter he disguises it it just
disappears ramirez is not looking for a
change up from lance lynn big from reyes
the dh
broken bat oh lance look what i found he
does birthdays and bar mitzvahs too the
ball kind of found him more than he
found the ball but it'll work save the
game wow that's our defensive play of
the night johnson with a one-out single
to bring up the catcher perez runner
goes on 3-2 swinging a miss strike three
the throw to second will be late
johnson's got a stolen base
two outs in the inning here comes you
chang
he struck him out and lynn storming
around on the mound talking to himself
as he heads to the dugout he's got seven
strikeouts through four the sox have two
on with one down here comes ryan goodwin
nine pitches and counting
good one right side that dribbles
through
monkat is around third he's going to
score the tying run and the throw into
third is well late it's an rbi single on
a long at bat for goodwin to deadlock
the game this is a change up again
after seeing four or five and the same
as bad he takes this through the right
side
so just like that it's a brand new game
tied at two and the sox with runners at
the corners the batter is leori garcia
first pitch he does it's a ground ball
to second clement for rosario the turn
is late and the sox take the lead it was
a slow ground ball
garcia beat it out it is three to two
runner scoring position two down base
open now jose ramirez to the plate every
start in july lance lin's gone at least
six that'll be quite quite the ride if
he can do that tonight
ryan driving a base hit right field
zimmer around third with the tying run
he will score and jose ramirez once
again delivers in the clutch
and ramirez with an rbi single has tied
this game at three cleveland now with
seven hits as harold ramirez comes up
up
it's got another one
second boomerang for lance lynn
kind of backs away reaches out the glove
makes a grab and that'll do it for
cleveland hernandez for the third time
line to right there is the first hit in
a white sox uniform for cesar hernandez
and it comes on two strikes bases are
loaded a single and two walks and now
the sox are really cooking something up
lake parker comes in he's got some
trouble he's got the bases loaded only
one out moncada against parker
swing and a miss he struck him out and
that is huge for blake parker two down
bases loaded two out for the rookie left
fielder for the sox payoff again from
parker
he missed for the fast ball and andrew
will take it it's a 4-3 socks lead but
the base is loaded for goodwin swing and
a missed strike three parker fans
goodwin to retire the white sox who do
score the go-ahead run andrew vaughan
two on one out zox trying to give some
leeway to this revamped bullpen
served into center field it's a base hit
but sheets got a late break they're
gonna wave them home anyway here's a
throw to the plate it's in time they got
him
wow
i am shocked they set him and a nice job
by bradley zimmer to throw him out and
keep it a one-run game this is the
arrival of craig kimbrell
being brought to the clubhouse mid-game
we'll have to trade out the bag
that will be replaced and we have one of
those former cubs on the mound ryan
tupara just a really solid year with the
cubs and leading off fran mill reyes and
it's swung and hammered high deep to
left down the line it goes go on
we are tied at four
so ryan to paris white sox debut
not the magical moment he envisioned a
towering blast down the left field line
by fran mill reyes and this ball game is
tied up at four so it was a single on a
pass ball and an error put garcia at
third tim anderson your turn
through the right side
tim anderson gives the socks the lead
5-4 in the eighth
in front of 36 000. second hit for tim
the first that left the infield and he
drives in his 37th run and a big one it
is base is loaded for the big fella and
now jose abreu
oh my goodness it hit him in the helmet
oh wow
jose abreu
got hit in the batting helmet
and it's 6-4 but that's not important
right now jose
just got
drilled
and now tony getting a little argument
with roberto perez
roberto was checking on him and i think
tony said
not to and now the benches have cleared
the bullpens have cleared
tony la russa is irate miguel cairo
holding back the white sox manager watch
it again i mean he gets hit
flush on the side of the helmet karen
check can't believe it jose is going to
stay in the game listen to the chant
it's three letters m b and p liam
hendrix on for the 46th time looking for
save number 26
looked like a big overhand hook and that
one was unhittable
and another trip around his mound
two gone
he has turned the mound into a ring of
fire
two out ramirez
in the ear
right side
abreu makes the catch
liam hendricks was lethal tonight and
the sox with a big eighth inning
take the opener
against second place cleveland